le président chèque Vaslav Avel a été
opéré d'urgence en Autriche d'une
perforation de l'intestin une opération
lourde très lourde Eveline
Goldman c'est dans cet hôpital d'insbru
que VAC laavavel a été opéré d'urgence
mardi le président tchck souffrait d'une
perforation du gros intestin pour ces
médecins il ne s'agit pas d'une tumeur
cancéreuse l'opération qui a duré 3h3
devrait lui permettre de se rétablir
mais il devra rester hospitalisé
plusieurs semaines vaclaavavel réélu en
janvier dernier à la présidence pour un
mandat de 5 ans a déjà été en décembre
96 opéré d'un cancer au poumon son état
de santé suscite l'inquiétude dans son
pays où l'écrivain de théâtre philosophe
et homme politique est très
populaire c'est pour son action contre
le régime communiste lors de l'invasion
de la Tchécoslovaquie par les chars
russes en 68 et son engagement au côté
des dissidents pendant la répression du
Printemps de Prague qu'il doit son
il est aussi celui qui a conduit son
peuple en 89 à la démocratie en 20 jours
appelés révolution de velour le
dissident tout juste sorti de prison
réussira à négocier la démission des
autorités
communistes